we covered monitoring gke clusters all
the way back in our first episode
but there are lots of new features in
cloud operations to help you observe and
manage your gke clusters
and the workloads that run on them today
i'm going to show you how to use cloud
operations for gke
to make sure your services are healthy
this is a stackdoctor
[Music]
right away you'll see that the new gk
monitoring dashboard looks very
different
instead of three tabs you now have lists
of all the different gke entities
like clusters namespaces and nodes
remember this information is aggregated
from all the projects being monitored by
your workspace
this gives you a single place to see
everything you're responsible for
managing
now right now you might be thinking well
that's great but i have a default
namespace in every cluster
how will i ever find what i need well
there's a really cool filtering feature
that will help you to find exactly what
you're looking for
for example if you have a copy of the
front-end service running three
different clusters
the filter lets you select the exact one
you want once you apply the filter the
entire dashboard is filtered to match
one of the things that's been kind of
hard to do in the past is to get an
aggregated view of the data
for example what does my resource
utilization look like across my
namespace
this new view makes it really easy to
get this kind of aggregation
and it'll scale no matter how many
resources are being monitored even if
you have thousands of ponds across
hundreds of namespaces but if you do
want to see all of those resources you
can click view all
that will let you see all of the
entities in that category if that list
is too overwhelming you can filter from
here too
at any point you can select a row in the
table to get its details for example
click a pod to open its details panel
this view has everything you need in one
place
metadata about the resource any
incidents that it has triggered and
metric unlocked data too
having a single place to access all this
information makes understanding what's
going on
much easier on the metrics tab you can
easily select a smaller subset of time
if you're trying to zero in on an
anomaly just drag a rectangle on the
chart that includes the time you want to
focus on
from any metric chart you can then
create a learning policy by clicking on
that link
this is a great way to quickly get
started with alerting on gk entities
right in context you can also get right
to the logs for the resource you've
selected
for example select the pod and click on
the logs tab to see the most recent logs
for it
if you're troubleshooting an issue you
can filter the logs for example you
might only want to see
error logs to figure out why a pod is
crashing to get more details click on
the open
and logging button that will open the
new logs viewer with your query
pre-populated and executed
this really makes it very easy to know
exactly what's going on with your
workloads
without having to figure out how to
select the resource you're looking for
you may recall that we covered using
logging with your gt clusters and
workloads in an earlier episode
we'll link to that below if you haven't
seen it already thanks for joining me
today
we took a look at the new gke monitoring
dashboard and learn how to use its
in-context capabilities
to set up alerting and pull up logs for
our workload
thanks for watching and come back soon
for more this is a stackdoctor stay
healthy out there